-How are you, Colin?
-Whoo! Hi, Seth. How are you?
-I miss having your energy
in the studio with me.
-Thank you. I miss being there.
This is gonna be weird,
but you like this
long, Hitchcockian shot
behind me, right?
-The cinematographer in you
has come out once again
with your framing there.
I think the whole interview
I'll be waiting to see
who's coming up behind you.
-Well, I think
it's also symbolic,
like the unconscious and --
you know what I mean?
-I think we all get it. We all
get what you're trying to do.
-Oh, I don't know about that,
but go ahead.
-[ Laughs ]
You are obviously
a born and raised New Yorker,
and I need to know.
Did you leave -- Have you left
at all during quarantine?
-Just little minor trips,
but not really, no.
I'm one of those --
I'm like those people, you know,
that don't leave during
the hurricane and the tornado.
The old guy that's like,
"I'm not leaving my house."
And then they die,
and you're like,
"You didn't want to leave."
-It does seem like this is --
It's like the source
of your powers.
It would seem very strange to me
if you left New York City.
-You're right.
Every time I leave,
when I come back, I almost --
my whole heart swells up in
the cab coming from the airport,
like, "Oh-ohh." I love New York.
-It's a beautiful drive
from the airport.
It should be noted, for those
who have never been here.
-Really is. Yeah.
-So, this is based on your --
the book is based on your show
"Red State, Blue State."
And you're not that optimistic
about the state of the nation.
You basically say we're like --
it's like a marriage couple
about to sign divorce papers.
-Yeah, I mean, obviously,
now that everybody --
everybody knows this is over.
But we still keep hanging on
like any marriage.
You're like, "They'll come
around. They'll change."
You know?
And what are we arguing over?
Money, like any married couple.
But the good thing
about my book, if I --
if I can say so,
is everything's a state.
So it's like -- I'm all about
table of contents at this point.
-[ Laughs ]
-You can read this book
and just there it is.
It's like -- You ever see "The
Founder" with Michael Keaton?
-Yeah, of course.
-And then he walks in McDonald's
and everything's organized.
That's how people are gonna feel
when they look at this book.
They go, "Oh, look, New Mexico."
Instead of like,
"Oh, French fries."
You know, like that.
-[ Laughs ]
So people will respond
to your book the way
Ray Kroc did when he saw
the original McDonald's?
-Exactly.
-The dedication -- I'm always
drawn to the dedication.
You dedicated this book
to someone very special.
-Yeah.
I dedicated it to myself.
-Right.
-Because one thing I'm getting
sick of is the false humility.
You know, that was,
like, a 1950s thing.
And then everybody
made fun of show business
in the '70s and '60s.
And Dustin Hoffman would
wear, like, a corduroy jacket
to the Oscars, and you know,
now, suddenly it's back to
"You're amazing.
You're the best,"
and people are hugging and
over-complimenting each other
and dedicating,
making these platitudes.
So I dedicated
to the person that did
the lion's share of the work
in this country -- me.
-It is. It's very refreshing
for someone to just call it --
Look, I think we all know
you did the lion's share
of the work here,
and you deserve the dedication.
-I mean, it was a Trump move.
I guess this is the right era
to do that, too.
-[ Laughs ]
We have a debate coming up
tomorrow night.
I think a lot of people
would love to see Colin Quinn
as a moderator
for a presidential debate.
What would be a question
you would ask?
-I would -- Well, one question
I would ask.
I would say, "Are you as
frightened as everybody else
that one of you actually will be
the president in November?"
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
It does feel very surreal
that it's finally happening.
Like, I knew it was coming,
and now, I kind of can't
wrap my head around the fact
that we're gonna watch
those two gentlemen
talk tomorrow.
-Kind of exciting, in a way,
you know what I mean?
-[ Laughs ]
You take issue with some of
the things that I feel like
are obviously held in
very high regard,
like the Bill of Rights.
You have some issues
with the Bill of Rights.
-Well, I mean,
the Bill of Rights is the worst.
It was an add-on anyway. It's
not part of the Constitution.
They were like, "Hey, we forgot
about the people."
And then they were like,
"Oh, let's give them
the Bill of Rights."
And first of all,
freedom of speech --
that's a figure of speech.
It's not supposed to be
freedom of speech.
Now we've seen --
Social media has exposed
how horrifying it is.
Because our country is not meant
to be a political --
We're not supposed to be
an intelligent country.
We were like an enthusiastic,
like, young, like, jock.
Fun, you know?
We were supposed
to be like France,
debating with chain smoking and,
you know, sitting in a café,
talking about
the nuances of politics.
And now that's
what we've become.
-And I think one of the things
that, you know,
whenever this comes up and there
is a seat on the Supreme Court,
we realize that
we're a lot of people
but not really a lot of us
have that much of a say.
-Yeah, I mean, all these people,
all these senators, Congress
who take care of everything --
Supreme Court.
They're like,
"Yeah, leave it at nine."
It's like, "Really? Isn't that
how the country started?
With nine?"
Wouldn't it be like 27 times
more people?
27 times.
It should be like 270 people
since there's
300 million people.
There were 1 million people
at the time.
But they're like, "No, nine
people, who, you know, would
rather be showing each other
pictures of their grandchildren.
Let's make that the deciding
factor on everything."
-Declaration of Independence.
Surely you don't have an issue
with that.
-Well, because,
you know, obviously,
all men are created equal.
If we set expectations --
Instead, if they just said,
"All men are created equal.
We know what you're gonna say."
-[ Laughs ]
-And then people
would have been like,
"Okay, as long as you know that,
go on."
-And the electoral college.
I think that people,
now more than ever,
are maybe thinking this wasn't
the best situation?
-Yeah, but at the time -- at
the time -- you look at a show
like "Deadwood," which is where
I get all my research from.
"Deadwood" -- you're dealing
with, like, psychotic guys,
oil barons, cattle barons --
they didn't want to be states.
They needed incentive
to be a state.
They're like, "Well, I'd rather
be a territory."
Being a territory means you
still can do whatever you want,
but you don't have to pay taxes,
so to get them in,
they kind of had to
give them something,
so they gave them two senators,
you know.
-I also -- I believe
I understand that
more from "Deadwood"
than anything else,
so all jokes aside...
-"Deadwood" says a lot,
you know?
-Although the pulling
of the strings
behind the scenes in Yankton...
[ Laughter ]
Hey, as a stand-up comedian,
I have to ask.
How is this era?
I mean, it's obviously
incredibly difficult for people
who do that full time.
And what do you think the future
of stand-up's gonna be?
-I think the future of stand-up
is gonna be like --
and I have been accused of using
this reference too often --
"Deadwood." No.
[ Laughter ]
-I think the future of
stand-up comedy --
It could be like "Deadwood."
Those outdoor shows, you know?
I think the future of stand-up
is gonna be below the equator
because only outdoor shows
are gonna matter.
There's no indoor.
Indoor is done for society now.
I thought it was all indoor.
It's gonna be all outdoor,
you know?
And so I think the big --
like baseball,
the Dominicans became
the best baseball players
because Dominican Republic
can play year-round.
So anybody that lives down South
is gonna have a lot more sets.
And that's gonna be
the big comedy boom.
-Oh, so, basically,
the Northeast,
which -- let's be honest --
has been a pipeline
for a long time
as far as American comedy,
you think it's gonna dry up?
-Yeah, unless global warming
happens.
You know what I mean?
-And I know -- like, I remember
in my high school,
there was a couple kids
who were good at baseball,
and their parents sent them down
to Florida to live full time.
Do you think that'll happen
where, like, a comedian
has a couple good sets
in New York and they're like,
"We got to get you down South"?
-Yeah, for a really funny guy.
They're gonna be like,
"We got to get you to Paraguay"
or something like that.
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you. It's always so great
to see you, Colin.
Thanks for being here.
-Thanks for having me on.